je lui ai dit moi benjamin avant de
savoir si on y croit je vois arriver
non j'étais et vous et pas de vous
demande de vous arrêter ce n'est pas le
seul à avoir fricoté je pense jouer
après ce quelque chose c'était la moins
bien mais ça n'avait pas bien les
magnifiques
je n'ai pas fait ces paris que de dos en
fait c est mal c'est une mauvaise blague
et en plus c'est en plus pire que
tourner là souffle et c'est vous dire à
quelle époque mais c'était l'époque de
drucker formidable sectionnelles 71
commence à se faire vieux cavaria lâchez
pas cette maman ça ne te crois qu'il m'a
fait qu'il m'a fait peur hein je veux
pourquoi d'inciter à temps j'étais un
soir je vais réaliser mon rêve c'est pas
vrai mon grand fantasme cette sortie
avec des spiders moi j'étais plus mais
le bie ben oui il faudrait voir avec
benjamin c'était une idée une sensation
j'ai un copain à la même époque et nuit
était avec mais avec l'accord et votre
copain il va du magnifique bienvenus il
s'appelle jamais il va gueuler initial
cgl gérard louvin
[Rires]